I had a question regarding thyroid
nodules okay let's talk about that that
really is a selenium deficiency
most of the selenium in the body is
stored in the thyroid and most of the
iodine trace mineral is also stored in
the thyroid so the thyroid needs both of
these trace minerals in the right ratios
if you're deficient in selenium and you
have too much of iodine that could be
very damaging to the thyroid and
vice-versa so you need the balance of
both of these trace minerals one thing
about selenium is that it acts as an
antioxidant okay
the base of that antioxidant is called
glutathione and glutathione helps to
reduce hydrogen peroxide that's
generated from the different biochemical
reactions that happen in the thyroid now
if you have an autoimmune disease of the
thyroid called Hashimoto's which by the
way the great majority of hypothyroid
type problems is Hashimoto's it's an
autoimmune situation but it generates a
lot of hydrogen peroxide as a byproduct
now when hydrogen peroxide builds up in
the tissues it creates damage to the
thyroid cells themselves and then that
can actually create this fibrosis of the
thyroid and that can be part of the
nodules as well so selenium has the
ability to not just get rid of the free
radical damage and the oxidation that
occurs from autoimmune but it can also
reduce the antibodies that are involved
in this condition
Hashimoto's selenium also is involved in
converting t4 to t3 so basically
selenium is just as important as iodine
in the thyroid function so the next
question is what type of selenium should
someone take to help this condition you
need an organic selenium and I'm not
talking about the definition of organic
being without pesticide I'm actually
talking about a different definition
involving a different type of bond of
the selenium molecule you have Organic
minerals which are usually plant-based
and bound to a protein and then you have
minerals that are elemental the type of
that I'm gonna recommend for either a
thyroid nodule or Hashimoto's would be
Celino methionine or Celino cysteine not
both one of the other but you would want
to take one of these if you have nodules
or Hashimoto's now there's two of the
things I'm gonna recommend to enhance
your results okay one is vitamin E but
don't get this synthetic version get a
version that has not just all the took
off roles but all the tocotrienols okay
in a complex and also take cod liver oil
with that you can get it in a little
pearls or actually in a liquid but the
combination is very very very important
because now you're getting vitamin A
vitamin D vitamin E and selenium and the
perfect combination alright thanks for
watching if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos